american airlines is canceling hundreds
of flights through at least mid-july
labor shortages the quick ramp up of
customer demand has led
the airline to adjust its scheduled
flying on saturday american airlines had
120 cancellations and the company is
projecting 50 to 80 flight cancellations
each day going forward
the number of people heading to the
airport is at its highest level since
the pandemic began the tsa screened more
than 2.1 million travelers yesterday
marks the highest level since may of
2019.
epi cruz the co-owner of las vegas-based
sunrise travel and tours says calls to
her business picked up about two months
ago
people uh who are vaccinated
are really eager to go out so most of
them are trying to go to you uh
to hawaii mexico
caribbean and some are europe
many of cruz's clients book travel to
the philippines through her company but
she says that region is requiring a
10-day hotel quarantine upon
entry so travel there has not started
picking back up just yet